good morning good morning look at this
view that we've got for you this morning
i know you're welcome uh we are incent
hives on the second day of the g7 summit
another busy day ahead for the prime
minister as he tries to resolve that
northern ireland brexit round
but also playing on his mind will be
what to do about lifting england's
remaining coveted restrictions
we all know that the 21st of june is the
date that's meant to happen
but the mood music suggests that could
all be delayed
by up to four weeks because of a sharp
rise in cases
of the delta variant we'll be speaking
to james cleverley in just a moment but
first let's bring in our political
correspondent tomorrow cohen standing by
for us
sit in westminster hello to tomorrow
come on they're going to extend it
another
month
i think that's looks like where it's
heading kay
essentially the consent emerging
consensus among ministers and officials
some of whom i spoke to
last night is that the data is all going
unfortunately in the wrong direction
there were over 8 000 new covid cases
yesterday
which takes us back to where we were at
the end of february
and of course we do have the vaccine
program now but the concern is that
almost all of these new cases are the
delta variant
the one that originated in india and
what we know
is that it is a huge amount 64
more admissible than the kent variant
and also
that it's particularly important for
people to have
two jabs in order to be fully
resistant to that variant and there are
still millions and millions of adults in
this country who have only had one
or have not had any jab at all so
some of the advice the government is
receiving is that it would be better to
delay
by two or even four weeks in order to
get
millions more of those jabs into arms
before
all social distancing is scrapped today
we are hearing from the nhs
confederation that's bosses of hospitals
they did a survey of their members and
found two-thirds of them said
they felt that unlocking on june the
21st was not
a good idea and the boss of that
organization
said it could have a devastating impact
on the nhs
to give you a sense of why scientists
are now advising the government to delay
this is a member of the nerve tag
advisory group professor ravi gupta
speaking to us
about that indian variant we know this
is a variant that
is not benign it has qualities which
enable it to
partly get around some of the antibodies
we make from vaccination and
past infection we know that it transmits
more easily and we can see some
mutations in the virus that
uh allow it to do that so i think this
is a wise uh
it would be a wise decision to to delay
uh to delay things
so boris johnson will be making the
final decision on that tomorrow
into monday it will be announced on
monday evening to the nation
what may be relaxed on the 21st of june
there may be some relaxation but
i think a full throwing off of all
social distancing
looking increasingly unlikely okay
okay for now tomorrow thanks very much
bringing in the foreign office minister
james cleverley now mr cleverly a
pleasure to have you with us this
morning thank you for joining us
one of the biggest factors if we do
delay past the 21st of june
is this indian variant if only we closed
our borders with india earlier
well okay good morning um one of the uh
one of the things that the the country
has uh the government has done
is put in place a very robust set of
border measures and those
water measures have been in place for
quite some time
we always knew there'd be a risk of
variance and that's why
the prime minister set out a number of
months ago
this progressive easing of lockdown but
with a number of
points where we would make assessments
and make
uh decisions and if necessary make
adjustments
um so we always knew there would be a
risk of uh
um coronavirus variants that's why we
put the program in place in the way we
did
on the 9th of april when we closed our
borders with pakistan and bangladesh
india had four times as many cases per
million as pakistan and twice as many as
bangladesh we should have closed our
borders with india at the same time
well as i say we we have uh incredibly
robust we had at the time incredibly
robust
uh border measures with a requirement
for testing pre-travel with a
requirement for isolation
uh on arrival but as i said we always
knew
there would be a chance of mutations and
variants
that's why this unlocking process was a
progressive one
and that's why we had these decision
points laid out
um and uh and that's why the um and
that's why the
the government the prime minister and
our scientific advisors will be
assessing
uh the data and making decisions uh to
be announced on monday
but why didn't we close our borders with
india when we did with pakistan and
bangladesh and they had fewer cases
well as i say okay we we had and we
still have
incredibly robust uh border measures so
that the the quarantining the
requirement for
pre-travel testing and post-arrival
testing those things were in place but
we always knew there'd be a danger
of variance whether yeah it'd be from
from india or somewhere else and that's
why we've had this
progressive carefully managed
easing of lockdowns with these decision
points set out through the
through the period
yeah but it's called the india variant
it's not called the pakistan variant or
the bangladesh variant and yet we
shut the borders with those two
countries but we didn't with india
and i suppose many well and certainly a
lot of people come to the conclusion
that it was a political decision
because the prime minister was
determined to go to india
and so he wanted to keep that trade um
corridor open
well as i say okay we we assess the
situations dynamically we see what
changes over time
and we have consistently made decisions
uh based on data based on science in a
progressive
way so that we can respond to
uh any changes and of course the nature
of fighting a pandemic is things change
things evolve and our decision making
has always been
uh in uh in response to the the data
about these changes these mutations
these variants and that's what's been
the driving force behind the decisions
that we have made in the past and we'll
be making in the near future
perhaps i could ask that a different way
then why did you think that india was
safe when
bangladesh and pakistan was not well
look
okay i've told you we've we had these
robust border measures in place
uh which covered uh a number of
countries uh
uh around the world and
uh what we what we are going to continue
to be
to do is to base our decisions
on the scientific information that's
provided for us
to try and ease the restrictions
uh that we are currently living under
here in the uk in a way that keeps us
safe
but also i mean i know you're down in uh
in cornwall
uh the importance of international
connectivity is
is key we are we're seeing through the
g7
world leaders coming together to address
some of the really important issues of
the day
including heroin virus but also
really important things like climate
change like
uh girls education like finding a way of
building back better
from this coronavirus that's why uh
there is always a balance to be struck
between um uh between border controls
and the requirement for um for people to
make decisions and and travel
internationally okay
but throughout this time we have very
robust border measures
and we will continue to uh to keep those
in places until
uh or evolve those until we've broken
the ground of ours okay the health
secretary said the link between cases
and deaths had been broken
but not completely severed by the
vaccine even though cases are
increasing just looking at the figures
for the seven day rolling average
around seven or eight people a day sadly
are presently losing their lives as a
result of kovid at 19.
uh what does that figure that death
figure what does that need to be
in order for us to get out of lockdown
well i'm not i'm not able to put a
a single figure on this because uh the
decisions
about changes to our current
restrictions will be made
in conjunction with the scientists based
on the most up-to-date evidence
and and and that's what the prime
minister and
uh the government will be doing over
this weekend for the announcement on
on monday but we should be very proud of
the vaccine program that we've had in
the uk
from the fantastic role out through the
uh nhs
um but also to the very speedy
research development and increasing
production which of course was done
because of the initial investment made
by the government
so the vaccination program is helping us
get out of this
um and as i say we will make decisions
with regard to lockdown based on the
most up-to-date information
can england fans sing when their team is
playing tomorrow
well look we know we know the things
which
increase transmissibility being in an
enclosed space being
in close proximity to the people
speaking at volume because
uh particles come from the mouth so we
would we would encourage people to do
things that we know
are safe be outside be socially
distanced
keeping your your face away from other
people's
faces we want people to enjoy the
football but we want people to enjoy the
football in a safe
way as possible and we know what that is
being outside being spread apart and not
not not shouting not singing
you're right i am down here in sentai's
beautiful backdrop behind me i'm just
sad that you aren't with us here mr
cleverley this morning but certainly the
french are
and it does appear that they've hijacked
this g7 summit doesn't it for brexit uh
negotiations
well actually what we've seen coming out
of this uh g7 summit is already some
fantastic announcements
on the really really important issues of
the day
including our battle collectively
against coronavirus and the rollout of
world-class vaccines to countries that
need it including a commitment
to girls education including a
commitment to fighting climate change
so this g7 summit is a meeting of
leaders
the uh the prime minister of the uk in a
global leadership role addressing some
of the
long-standing global issues facing us
all
uh just a quick thought on that before i
let you go i know you've got lots of
people to talk to
this morning um we heard from uh number
10 sources
telling us that nothing is off the table
as far as brexit negotiation or
the brexit deal is concerned the french
are looking at that very differently
indeed they say the deal's done
and if you try to extend past the 30th
of june we'll see you in court
is the 30th of june the deadline that
the brits are working to
well the uk throughout this process has
always come
at this pragmatically we want to have a
successful trading relationship
with the eu but but the g7 isn't uh you
know
it isn't a branch line of the brexit
negotiations it is a
really key international summit with uh
world leaders
um convened and led by the prime
minister down there in
wonderful beautiful cornwall but we are
thinking about global issues global
trade
uh global health security the education
of
uh young people particularly girls
around the world and how we build that
better this is what the g7 summit is
about
it's not a branch line of the brexit
negotiations and i'm sure that the world
leaders who
have come together will focus on those
really important issues that affect
every single person
on the planet but i am asking you
about brexit if i may 30th of june is
that a date that's set in stone as well
to try to sort out this on pass or not
yeah okay so what happens when you ask
me the same questions i will give you
the same answer and as i said these
are these g7 negotiations are not a
branch line of the brexit negotiation
but i'm not asking you about q7 mr
cleverley i'm asking you about brexit
yeah and i just said uh this uh this
weekend
this focus is on these global
issues we we have the privilege of
hosting
uh global leaders and the prime minister
will be working with them to address
global issues including the pandemic
uh including um uh you know
how we how we uh save our planet how we
improve
the environment how we educate girls
around the world these are
globally significant issues and they
deserve the full focus of the prime
minister and the world leaders down
how sorry are you that you're not here
the sun's shining they're gonna have a
barbecue on the beach
later on i love i love cornwall my
my my wife's grandparents retired to
cornwall and we
visited quite regularly uh just around
uh uh
around padso um spending sunny
sunny days on the beach uh in boobies
bay uh so i absolutely love cornwall and
uh i look forward to getting back there
i know
uh can't get there can't be there at the
moment but i can't wait to get back
i'm going to padstow for me tea it's
lovely to talk to you mr cleverley
thanks very much indeed for joining us
thank you
thank you thanks a lot now it's going to
be a busy day for the g7 leaders as was
outlined there by the
foreign minister let's take a look at
what will be happening
here in cornwall boris johnson will have
a morning bilateral meeting with the
french president
emmanuel macron and then the summit's
morning session will be
around the theme of building back
resilient focusing on the opportunity
for a green recovery and tackling
geopolitical challenges
in the afternoon the discussions turned
to foreign policy
including the distribution of vaccines
and the global efforts to fight covid19
then in the evening the leaders and
their partners will meet
on the beach behind me for a barbecue
supper where they'll enjoy a fly pass
from the red arrows
and toast marshmallows on an open fire
isn't that lovely there's a height in
security though around cornwall for this
g7 as you can well imagine
and uh none more so than off the coast
of the county
where there are more than five of
britain's warships
and they've been situated there for the
last three or four days
but this level of security doesn't come
without its impact on locals
as i found out yesterday when i went out
onto the ocean on a small fishing vessel
island which is
more than a thousand people have been
named in the queen's birthday honours
list that's just been released the
awards are dominated by people who
volunteered during the pandemic as well
as those who helped develop
the first coronavirus vaccines either
bennett reports
in a year that demanded heroes they
weren't in short supply
and those whose efforts have helped us
all fight back against the virus
are now being honored we started trails
here in the first week professor andrew
pollard oversaw the development of the
oxford vaccine
which was achieved in just eight months
he's been knighted for services to
public health
but says credit should go to a lot more
than just him and his team
and perhaps even more important to the
people who took part in the clinical
trials
and who actually made this possible and
have brought
this vaccine that's now being delivered
all around the world
so they're heroes as well i guess they
are all heroes they are they're all part
of this army that's been fighting
against coronavirus with us leading that
army was kate bingham chair of the
vaccine task force
she's been made a dame as has professor
sarah gilbert
another of the life-saving vaccine
pioneers
their colleague divya chattermanic led
the clinical trials for the jabs
convincing manufacturers to conduct them
in britain she's been made an obe
the culmination of something she says
began with what her father said
when she left home in india to study in
the uk
he said do good be good and
do something amazing so that you do get
to meet the queen my dad did pass away
in december so for me this is an
ultimate culmination the honors is an
ultimate culmina
culmination of i hope i've done good i
hope i've been able to do
something um and at some point maybe
meet the queen if not in person but at
least this this comes just
as close these pans they look rather big
but they just about make all the food
that we need
but it's not just the scientists who
have made a difference andrew aliwalia
runs a charity feeding london's homeless
and has been awarded the british empire
medal
before the pandemic they were cooking
900 meals a week at most
but when covid hit that became 5000 as
they responded to all those in need
some of these people they didn't have
money because they had been furloughed
or they didn't have jobs or they were
self-employed and they couldn't prove
that
they didn't know where their next meal
was coming from and
i'm a massive believer in that every
single human being on the planet
needs to have at least one hot meal a
day footballer raheem sterling is among
the non-covid related honours
given an mbe for services to racial
equality and sport
while there are knighthoods for two
prominent tory donors philanthropist
william adley and trail finders founder
michael gooly
who have been honoured for services to
charity their companies both donated
half a million pounds to the
conservatives
in the run-up to the last election but
the overriding theme of those being
recognized
is the pandemic the worst of times
bringing out the best in many
iva bennett sky news
also on the honors left chef and bake
off judge
prue lee she has been made a dame
the liverpool captain jordan henderson
is appointed mbe
after he raised four million pounds for
the nhs with other premier league
footballers
and robert rinder tv's judge rinder
becomes an
mbe for services to holocaust education
and awareness
and let's bring you this incredible
escape story this morning should we
ready
a lobster fisherman is recovering in
hospital after he was
swallowed whole by a humpback whale 56
year old michael parkhardt was
driving around diving i should say
forgive me around 45 meters down off the
coast of massachusetts
when the attack happened he estimates
that he was in the well's mouth for
about 30 seconds and described how
everything in his world just went dark
i was just about at the bottom and i
just felt this
truck hit me and everything just went
dark
and i could just feel just
just hard stuff all around me like
and i just thought did i just get eaten
by a white shark and
then i said no i don't feel any teeth
and i said oh my god i'm in the mouth
of a whale and again welcome back to the
g7 summit here
incentives in cornwall government
ministers
say a decision has not yet been taken on
whether to delay the lifting of
england's remaining coveted restrictions
by
up to four weeks it comes amid growing
concern over rapidly increasing cases
and the higher transmissibility of the
delta variant a short time ago the
foreign office minister james cleverley
said a final decision on whether to
extend the lockdown would come shortly
i'm not able to put a a single figure on
this because
uh the decisions about changes to
our current restrictions will be made in
conjunction with the scientists based on
the most up-to-date evidence and
and and that's what the prime minister
and
uh the government will be doing over
this weekend
well chair of the defense select
committee tobias elwood is joining us
now hello to mr ellwood good to talk to
you thank you
um it does look as though we will have
at least another two to four weeks
of uh lockdowns some well it looks as
though
the delta the india variant is
responsible should we have shut the
border with india earlier
uh that's a good question i think that
we will come back to
i think we need to look to the future
there are difficult questions ahead
we'll learn more on monday what the
prime minister wants to do looking at
that most
up-to-date data three choices uh stay as
we are
you know keep the restrictions in place
go for that opening that we've all been
wanting
or do some halfway house where we're
able to ease certain restrictions allow
great
larger weddings to take place and so
forth the two things i would like to see
change are allowing people who've been
vaccinated twice and after
a time period able to travel uh to the
eu
so us joining in with that digital
passport scheme
that's already up and running and then
we know that it's the vaccinations that
gets us out of this
let's continue to vaccinate into the
teenagers as well
that is the two recommendations that i
would make
how important are g7 summits do you
think that's where we are of course this
morning it's beautiful here
in sentais just a little way up the
course from
coast i should say in bournemouth where
where you are but how important is that
that these uh world leaders get together
well firstly congratulations to cornwall
on hosting this
incredible event the watching the images
that you've been putting forward is just
uh quite amazing but you know this is
the first time these groups of people
the most powerful
people in the western world have got
together for some time
and from my perspective you introduced
me as the chair of the defense select
committee
you know the world is not in a good
place the security trajectory
uh is is taking us into a very unstable
uh era more so than during the cold war
and we have such a group of of
challenges ahead of us
a complex you know series of challenges
from climate change from biosecurity
but also the rise of china you know we
have an attitude towards china
but we don't have an actual mission a
policy of such
what we choose to do over the next few
years
will actually to determine how the next
few decades play out
and i think the leaders at the g7 are
starting to appreciate that
should russia and china have seats at
the g7 table do you think would that
help in any way
well the if you like the the test to be
at that table is whether you support
democratic values and clearly russia and
china don't
but what we're not doing is leveraging
the power that the g7
has uh president the prime minister has
also invited
uh korea australia and india and when
you place
all those nations together what i would
call the d10 group of nations which is
where i think the g7 should go you've
got over half the world's
gdp that's quite a standard that's quite
a powerful position
of which to persuade the rest of the
world that there are values
standards that we're willing to defend
and support and i'm afraid the west has
become
rather risk-averse uh and part of of
what joe biden and the prime minister
were trying to do
with the signing of this atlantic
charter is to say we do
need to regroup we need a counterweight
as to what china
and both russia are doing but for the
moment absolutely no they should not
have a seat at that table
um talk to me about the cuts in foreign
aid i know that you were very much
against that uh the uk the only
nation here at the g7 that has seen a
cut in its foreign aid from 0.7
in our case to not point five percent
you had hoped uh
with some of your fellow backbenchers to
try to get that overturned earlier on in
the week where are we now with that
well we're going to keep pressing this
and recognize that you know the
discussions you're having at the g7
this has not played out well this is not
in the spirit of global britain
but i can only stress that the the cold
war that we're going to face over the
next couple of decades
is not going to be a buildup of military
might either side of
an iron curtain it's going to be far
subtler than that it's going to be china
nudging us out as favored nation status
with our friends across the commonwealth
as they lure and ensnare evermore
countries into
their programs whether it be
infrastructure or technology or indeed
military connections as well so our soft
power counts every time
we retreat our programs in places like
yemen and so forth
they could either get filled by
extremism taking advantage of our
departure or indeed by china and russia
that quickly move in
and pursue a very different agenda
tell me about um the uh big ben just at
the side of you there tell me that your
boys made that rather than you
uh yeah they did make it it was a
project and
uh it's on their insistence that it's
there but i appreciate it's a bit of a
distraction but a good
fun project to do not a distraction at
all i just wondered whether you'd had
any involvement in it it's good to talk
to you mr elder thank you very much
indeed for joining us
thank you clever sons hasn't he now it's
a busy weekend for the queen after
meeting g7 leaders last night this
morning
she will be in central london for her
birthday parade a scaled-down version of
uh trooping the colour
as our royal correspondent rhiannon
mills reports
her majesty was definitely the star
attraction at last night's
g7 reception in the striking
setting of the eden project there was
only
one star the queen and expert in these
photo
opportunities on sparkling form
how's that i was supposed to be looking
as if you're enjoying it
yes for the leaders this was clearly a
moment
not to forget all of them jockeying to
have their time
with a head of state without equal
it was a real coup for the prime
minister not just the monarch but her
family
traveling to cornwall to support him the
ultimate display
of royal diplomatic charm
number 10 know that a meeting with the
queen will literally
mean the world to some of these leaders
yes the impact
is subtle and that's why it's described
as soft power but
so often over the years it has made a
huge difference
in securing those foundations of
friendship when difficult discussions
lie ahead but for the prince of wales
this was an evening of opportunity when
it comes to the climate
crisis in a first for a g7 summit
10 global ceos who joined him and prince
william
to meet the leaders and discuss how
governments
and business can work hand in hand
the prince even using one of the prime
minister's slogans
to put his point across to build back
better
we need above all a truly effective
partnership
between government and business
the fight against this terrible pandemic
provides if ever one was needed
a crystal clear example of the scale
and sheer speed at which the global
community can
tackle crises when we combine
political will with business ingenuity
and public mobilization
fashion designer stella mccartney is
supporting the prince
and believes that only with changes in
laws and regulation
can her industry become more green
for me to be there with these world
leaders is
really exciting very terrifying because
i'm desperate to get across
some of the facts and realities of of
how
unfashionable the fashion industry is
the queen camilla and kate squeezed in
another engagement
thanking volunteers who'd worked so hard
during the pandemic
the monarch on fantastic form clearly
pleased to be back out
on royal duties with a busy weekend
ahead with
tea with president biden and the first
lady on sunday
and her official birthday parade taking
place at windsor castle
later today there is a knife i know
there is
rhiannon mills sky news inside
turn off a look at the morning papers uh
joining us nigel nelson the political
editor of the sunday mirror and sunny
people
and in addition sofia gaston the
director of the british
foreign policy group good morning t-bo
thanks for joining us
this morning let's start with you nigel
if we may and the
express front page at sausage wars boris
turns up the heat
indeed he does and in a few minutes time
he'll be meeting
uh president macron for a a one-to-one
uh so it probably wouldn't be advisable
to have sausages on the menu for
breakfast although
um they'll certainly be discussing them
i mean the trouble with this is
that we never gave enough thought to
northern ireland in the early
days of brexit and what it would
actually mean to share
an eu border with ireland so now we're
paying the price for that
now it may be they can negotiate a way
around this
chilled meats rule which won't allow
allow um
a non-eu country to import it into
a one that's following eu rules but even
so
we actually negotiated this deal and it
seems to me
that if uh both macron and angela merkel
dig their heels in we have to accept
that the deal that we negotiated
well we'll have to wait and see on that
won't we certainly that is very much uh
on the agenda
when the two leaders meet as you say um
in around about 40 minutes
time nigel sophia um you're interested
in pages six and seven of the times i
thought
i was listening to him live yesterday
when the uh prime minister was talking
about the world being more feminine
yes yesterday was the first kind of real
kickoff day
of the g7 summit we had all the world
leaders
streaming in and the big focus of the
day was on
aid foreign aid and also vaccinations
how we can vaccinate the developing
world
some big commitments came out of it of
course many campaigners think we should
have gone further but
there was a big announcement from the uk
about about half
billion pounds uh more we're going to be
pushing
into uh getting girls into education and
so i think this is where this
term about making the world a more
feminine place comes into i think
there's a real sense that we need to
make sure that
all women and girls have the opportunity
to participate
in uh public life and and the global
economy so
a big commitment there and of course the
government trying to get out on the
front foot there's been a lot of
scrutiny
for its decision to temporarily reduce
the uk's aid budget so i think this was
a
kind of shot across the bow to try and
get ahead of those headlines
um this is something you both want to
talk about i know but let's start with
you nigel um
first if i may uh mirror pages six and
seven freedom delayed i was putting that
point
to i don't know if you heard james
cleverley at the start of the program
this morning he was very reluctant to
say had anything
potentially extending for a month or so
had
nothing to do with us keeping the
borders open with india
well if we'd actually closed the borders
earlier
we might have got the the delta variant
in this country
um i'm sure he does say something like
that but i think there was a mistake the
way that they did it
i mean in fact going out at an operative
up to 1.4 which means that for every
10 infected people 14 others will catch
the disease
uh at the moment that the variant is
doubling
uh on every nine days so it was 8 000
there yesterday it'll be 16 000 a day by
next week
64 000 uh by next month
and so although hospitalizations are low
because of the vaccine
inevitably on those figures they will go
up so
unfortunate though this is and it is
disappointing
i don't see the government has any
choice but to
delay ending restrictions for another
month
sophia what's the eyes there
well i think everybody's feeling a
little bit bereft because we were so
close
uh there was this sort of sense that
maybe we were getting out of the woods
but
uh i think we're back to that sort of
feeling of uncertainty
it's quite clear no one wants to go in
for another round of lockdown
so the government knows that whenever
they lift it has to be for the final
time
the question is have we broken that link
between cases hospitalizations and
deaths
looks as though the vaccines are helping
us weaken it but we're not quite there
and that's partly because it takes
14 weeks from when you get your first
dose until when you're fully protected
and this new variant seems to really
test the vaccines to their limits you
need to have your
double jab protection so even all these
people who are getting vaccinated now
it'll be some time until they're fully
protected so
it's just really a race against time i
think nobody is taking these decisions
lightly but it doesn't feel like we have
much choice
uh in the matter at this moment and just
while we've got you sofia talk to me
about the guardian front punch
james cleverley was talking about the
football and saying that england fans
shouldn't shout or sing which is quite
frustrating i'm sure perhaps they'll
watch the footy at home
instead but also there's another issue
as far as the football is concerned on
the front page of the
guardian yes so this is all about
footballers taking the knee at the euros
essentially the government has said uh
look do do as you wish we're not going
to
stop you taking the knee um but they
haven't come out and explicitly
advised fans not to boo when this takes
place and so
uh labour leader kia stamos is holding
their feet to the fire and saying that
that that's what real leadership would
be is to say it's important to respect
this act as well as allowing them to do
it in the first place so
um i think this is an issue which will
continue to sort of
ring around the euros but of course that
taking the knee is
is a signal of of sort of um
raising protests about racial inequality
and i think that there are a lot of
people who appreciate that and agree
that that's a problem in our society
i think the question of the debate at
the moment is really
is this too political for a sporting
event
um so i think a lot of heat will be now
on the government to
to whether or not they actually
specifically ask fans to
to allow this to take place